an MSNBC panelist is floating a ticket
for 2024. I
I of all that I've heard you know we've
heard about
we need DeSantis oh yeah DeSantis is
great we need Trump I still like Trump
people a lot of people don't like them
anymore I still like Trump we need I
don't know Ted Cruz I love Ted Cruz that
would be great uh we need this guy we
need that guy we need this guy I've now
heard this is my favorite ticket
uh MSNBC take it away
let me throw out a couple of other
can so you've got Bell demmings right
you've got Liz Cheney
um
Sherry Beasley Tim Ryan a top Democrat
suggested to me watch for Tim Ryan in
years in the future to run for president
I mean I don't know do you count these
folks out I I is is are many of them
maybe the right candidate in the wrong
state
well what about if we have we pair up
Liz Cheney and Stacy Abrams and actually
start talking about Universal voting and
election reform I could see them doing
kind of a czar thing with the
administration that's completely
bipartisan that would be exciting I mean
stuff does turn over and that's what
point that the president can create and
there is definitely an appetite for this
kind of movement of like how do there's
not one American who has not experienced
an election uh election day and said
this is flawed there has to be a better
way
before I get to her point on elections
yes I endorse this ticket
I I will campaign
for Cheney Abrams in the Democrat
primary yes this is this is what we need
if Cheney Abrams
run in 2024 some of the biggest losers
in the United States
even with
the power going out and the water pipes
bursting and the camera's turning off
and the machine's malfunctioning even
with that Republicans will win 57 states
so let's do it baby
I'm in every all of the 57 states that
Barack Obama
remembered that's that's what the
Republicans are going to win if they get
it uh on her point though
she makes a very important Point here
she says they should run on Election
reform
election reform is very important to
people now she is describing election
reform as make it even easier to cheat
rig it even more for the Democrats she
calls it Universal voting
does that mean everybody has a legal
right to vote in America everybody's had
the legal right to vote
for a century and a half
everybody has had the federal government
enforcing the legal right to vote for
what 60 years now at least
so what is she possibly talking about
she's saying basically
make sure that every single person casts
a ballot that means more ballot
harvesting means fewer idea requirements
it means a lot more dead people voting
it means we're going to be counting
until the Democrats win so her what she
means by election reform is really bad
but when she says there at the end she
says there's not one person in America
who's gone to vote recently who has
thought this is a functioning system and
she's totally right about that
where's Ian bremmer to call her an
election denier
let's go come on Ian come on liberal
establishment she's an election denier
she's saying that there are serious
problems with our voting system oh right
everybody says that
every single person says and thinks that
it's just that when inconvenient people
when enemies of the established regime
and ruling class when the conservatives
the actual conservatives come out and
say that that's the problem
we're not allowed to point it out
MSNBC can talk about it all day
it's it is a big issue and and I think
conservatives and Republicans should
take her advice seriously to Heart
because
if we want to get results like Florida
and Texas and Ohio
we need really good strong conservative
government in those States yeah we need
the DeSantis model in those states that
would be awesome
but you know Ohio I don't know you
wouldn't say that Ohio is kind of
leading the charge for the conservative
revolution in America in the way that
Florida is right or even Texas is not
doing quite the same thing
what
what was the big factor there especially
in Ohio which is kind of a purple state
now some people are trying to say no
it's a firmly Red State but that's not
quite true
Ohio has is very much in play if if
anyone turned it into a red state it is
Donald Trump actually certainly before
trump it was a very purple State leaning
to a blue State sometimes so
what's the big determining Factor here I
think it's probably this election issue
and
the Liberals don't want to talk about it
because they're they're winning now
because they were able to rig the
elections using the excuse of covid
the conservatives do want to talk about
it but that's there's that squishy block
the kind of squishy establishment
conservatives who want to be liked by
the New York Times who want to get
invited on CNN who want to seem really
Posh especially look Thanksgiving and
Christmas are around the corner they
don't want to be called a crazy kooky
wacky person by you know their lesbian
purple-haired niece I was going to say
nephew maybe nephew who knows these days
at the dinner table and so they want to
seem like they're really respectable
sort of establishment conservatives and
they don't want to raise this question
of election Integrity either
it's important and a lot of the
conservatives the people are that
everyone's looking up to right now
Ron DeSantis
Greg Abbott
they they took election Integrity
seriously especially knowing that that
they and their friends would be on the
ballots they took it seriously and every
other Republican should too right now
head on over to goodranchers.com Knowles
you know I love spending the holidays
with my family and one of the ways I
like to do that is with delicious meat
from good ranchers as a special gift to
our listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order these are two 12 ounce Steakhouse
quality Cuts that's a 70 value for free
you don't want to miss this offer let me
tell you why Black Angus tastes better
and is more tender than any other beef
black angus meat is marbled in such a
way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
help you save as much as possible if you
subscribe to good ranchers today you can
lock in your price and avoid these
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it go to goodranchors.com
Knowles use code Knolls at checkout for
this special offer that is
goodranchors.com Knowles for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks with your
order for free good ranchers American
Meat delivered you know Twitter now is
in absolute chaos and and Elon Musk is
another agent of chaos and Agent of
Change
Elon Musk comes in and he just
democratized the blue check mark
the tyranny of the blue checks is over
because now if you pay eight bucks you
too can have your own blue check mark
now why would you do that I don't know
because now if everyone can have a blue
check mark then the blue check mark
doesn't mean anything but think about
think about what that means
the blue check mark
was intended for verification
the blue check mark
means that this person is who he says he
is and the reason it developed in the
first place is because if you had public
figures then you would have lots of
accounts come in to impersonate those
public figures so you needed a check
mark to say who is the actual public
figure will The Real Slim Shady please
stand up
now the meaning of the check mark
started to change long before Elon Musk
showed an interest in Twitter
it was when Richard Spencer the white
identitarian activist uh aroused the ire
of everybody and all the people in
Silicon Valley
and so they took his check mark away
it was very strange why did they took
his check mark away why because he was
no longer Richard Spencer
did he cease to be Richard Spencer no
it's because they recognize that the
blue check mark connoted not just
uh a sort of identity not just a
verification but a certain Prestige if
you had a blue check mark you were very
very fancy it was the sort of Lords and
surfs model of Twitter
and that now
uh now Elon has totally changed that and
the blue check mark just means you paid
eight dollars
is the same sort of thing that happens
with uh our Republic or our sacred
democracy you hear that phrase when uh
Ian Bremer or somebody calls me an
election denier because I raise basic
questions about why the security cameras
went out for eight hours or why it's
taking five days to count the votes you
know stuff that any normal person would
have been able to ask five years ago but
we're not allowed to ask it anymore and
when when the Democrats refer to our
sacred democracy
they don't say our Republic because they
want to tie our form of government to
their own party which is the Democrat
Party and it's ironic because when the
word democracy pops up it doesn't pop up
at the Constitution or the Declaration
of Independence does crop up in the
Federalist Papers always negatively oh
is it disapproval but anyway they refer
to our democracy but one has to
recognize that our democracy or our
Republic or just our system of
government
is not the same one that it used to be
the way that our government works today
is not the way that it worked in 1796.
the way that our government works today
is not the way that it worked in 1885.
or
1955 or it has changed dramatically over
time
so we use the same terms to refer to our
government
our our democracy our Republic or
whatever
but we're not referring to the same
thing we we have the same symbol just
like the blue check mark it's the same
symbol but it means something totally
different than it used to mean even just
a few years ago
and whereas it may not have been proper
or right to raise questions about the
elections 20 years ago 30 years ago 50
years ago
the system has changed the the system of
Elections has changed and the
conservatives are a little bit slow on
this but it's it's the it's the Liberals
main trick I mean this is the thesis of
my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds number one National
bestseller still selling very well makes
a great Christmas present is that the
Democrats are just much more Adept at
using language and that they uh pervert
language as the primary means of
achieving their political ends
so when they refer to these things
when they refer to men as women or when
they're refer to
foreign Nationals as undocumented
dreaming future Americans or when they
refer to rigged elections that they
admitted or rigged in Time Magazine as
you know the the persistent and enduring
symbol of our sacred democracy they're
lying to you they're deceiving you and
and then they Gaslight you whenever you
raise the question whenever you point
out that that that the way that they're
describing things does not correspond to
reality today's music Monday we've got a
t-swift video
again I I don't think I've ever
intentionally listened to an entire
Taylor Swift song
in my whole life I don't really know
anything about the girl but her last
song
seemed to me fairly conservative which
was jarring to me because I was told she
was a huge lib so anyway the producers
have teed up a t-swift song the rest of
the show continues now if you don't want
to miss it then you got to become a
member and of course you don't want to
miss it so click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign